eden roc robert de niro qui n'a accordé
d'interview 40 m2 s'y fier
il est la star il était une fois
l'amérique film de 3h40 où il passe de
12 à 60 ans un vieux projet mais je sais
rencontré sergio il ya dix jours il
était une fois l'amérique
hamada moi je voulais rencontrer régeard
depardieu voulait aussi
fergie bac de limoges étaient d'accord
sur le principe je ne sais rien du sud
hier c'était notre premier contact dans
la suite bien des années après le
producteur de kings of comedy des
syndromes décida de produire le film il
me fit rencontré sergio dans des dîners
en a parlé on a décidé d'y penser un
jour sergio sur plusieurs jours de
raconter l'histoire puis menacé liant en
fait c'est son récit de sept ou huit
heures qui m'a décidée il a dit vous
séduire
il a raconté mais j'étais intéressé
c'est un beau projet
quel match et j'ai beaucoup de temps à
penser parce que ce n'est plus longtemps
que je pense
chaque film s'est coincé sans imaginer
vous avons dit deux fois l'ouest il ya
dedans tous mes angoisses tous les
souvenirs tous les 30 ans
et il ya dedans
plus cher chaussures plein seulement un
fils ou un casteur juif c'est chine sur
les souvenirs chez nous sur la marché un
jour je voulais passer sur l'amitié
ces chiffres une certaine amérique
ai-je certain cinéma / tourner
américaine a one comme le ton en
tournant un an et en vieillissant de 35
ans pendant ce voyage
l'on pense que lorsqu'on tourne si
longtemps sauront ils sont à mesure
qu'elle nous quelques fonds peut
personnellement pas dans ce film mais
quelquefois c'est difficile et on peut
dire beaucoup de choses en faveur de
films rapide qui vous permet de ne pas
perdre votre hymne votre enthousiasme la
dynamique
je suis fort lié au sommet pendant un an
avec des effets spéciaux tout ce
vieillissement présentent des problèmes
qui peuvent être plus intenable ça le
problème très dures comme les traces